the tech industry is evolving rapidly
and companies are now prioritizing
efficiency scalability and deployment
devops Bridges the gap between
development and operations teams
ensuring seamless collaboration faster
development cycles and quicker releases
in 2023 businesses are seeking
innovative solutions to meet the
ever-changing demands of the customers
and that's where devops comes into play
it enables organizations to deliver high
quality products faster ultimately
increasing customer satisfaction and
maximizing profit so if you want to stay
ahead of the curve and be part of the
tech Revolution devops is way to go but
how so hey everyone and welcome to this
video on top devops course by simply
Loan in this video we'll clear your
doubts regarding the best devops course
you can choose to enter or advance in
your career as a devops engineer but
before we begin if you enjoy watching
these videos and find them interesting
then subscribe drive to our Channel
because we bring the best videos for you
daily also hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from Simply loan so
let's start this video with the most
discussed topic when it comes to a job
the salary of a devops engineer do you
guys know that a devops engineer working
in the United States earns around 123
355 dollars per year the same devops
engineer in India earns around 8 lakh
rupees annually and that's not the
salary of a lead devops engineer Elite
devops Engineers salary can go up to 172
thousand dollars in the United States
and 22 lakh rupees per annum in India so
the motive of this video is to help you
guys choose the right course to enter or
advance in devops in the future on that
note we introduce to you the
postgraduate program in devops by simply
loan if you are eager to become a devops
engineer and Propel your career to new
heights then simply learns postgraduate
program in devops is undoubtedly the
right choice for you this comprehensive
devops training course will unlock your
true potential by providing you with a
solid foundation in formalizing and
documenting development processes along
with creating a self-documenting system
this program will not show you expertise
and advanced tools like puppet salt
stack and ansible enabling you to
achieve cell governance and automated
management at skill upon successful
completion you will earn a Caltech ctme
post graduate certificate a testament to
your expertise in the devops domain join
our Vibrant Community of devops
professionals who have harnessed the
power of Simply learns postgraduate
program to accelerate their careers
check out the link mentioned in the
description box below and enroll how to
become a successful devops engineer now
that we know why devops is a hot career
choice let's explore the rules and
responsibilities of a devops engineer as
a devops engineer you will be at the
heart of the development and operations
process driving collaboration and
efficiency your primary responsibilities
will include continuous integration and
deployment you will Design Implement and
manage automated pipelines to enable
frequent and reliable code deployments
infrastructure management devops
Engineers are responsible for managing
and scaling the infrastructure including
Cloud resources and on-premises systems
monitoring and troubleshooting ensuring
the smooth functioning of applications
and identifying and resolving issues
promptly
security and compliance implementing
security measures and ensuring
compliance with industry standards and
regulations collaboration and
communication facilitating effective
communication between development
operations and other teams to ensure a
smooth workflow tooling and automation
selecting and implementing the right
tools and Technologies to automate
processes and optimize development
workflow performance optimization
continuously analyzing and improving
system performance to enhance user
experience remember a devops engineer is
not just a rule it's a mindset of
continuous Improvement and innovation
excited about the opportunities devops
offers great now let's talk about the
skills you will need to become a
successful devops engineer coding and
scripting strong knowledge of
programming languages like python Ruby
or JavaScript and scripting skills are
essential for Automation and Tool
deployment
system administration familiarity with
Linux or Unix and Windows systems
including configuration and
troubleshooting cloud computing
Proficiency in Cloud platforms like AWS
Azure or Google Cloud to deploy and
manage applications in the cloud
containerization and orchestration
understanding container Technologies
like Docker and container orchestration
like kubernetes is a must
continuous integration or deployment
experience with CI CD tools such as
Jenkins gitlab Ci or Circle CI to
automate the development workflow
infrastructure as code
knowledge of IAC tools like terraform or
ansible to manage infrastructure
programmatically monitoring and logging
familiarity with monitoring tools like
Prometheus graphene and logging
Solutions like elk stack acquiring these
skills will not only make you a valuable
devops engineer but will also open doors
to exciting job opportunities to enroll
in the postgraduate program in devops
today click the link in the description
box below don't miss this fantastic
opportunity to invest in your future so
before we end this video let's take a
minute to hear from our learner who have
experienced massive success in their
careers through a postgraduate program
in devops
I realized that devops and cloud
computing were emerging field and I got
interested in them after some research I
decided to pursue the post-graduate
program in devops with help of Simply
learn with Caltech ctm after completion
of course I cracked a job with a hike of
100 and I'm very happy with it I learned
to use different Tools in Cloud as well
as devops such as easy tone instance ECS
container technology such as Docker
kubernetes keep learning keep investing
in yourself and give up Skilling so
thank you so much guys for joining us
today to explore the world of devops and
the incredible career opportunities it
presents remember the tech industry is
revolving rapidly and devops is the key
to staying ahead in the game so don't
hesitate to embrace this exciting career
path if you find this video helpful
please give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to our channel for more exciting Tech
related content if you have any question
or want to share your thoughts drop a
comment below so thank you so much for
being here today we'll see you next time
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign